after spending months claiming not to
want to take away your gas stoves
Liberals are taking away your gas stoves
which is unfortunate because gas stoves
are great they're much better than
electric stoves but that is less
important than what the liberal fatwa
against proper cooking equipment says
about how the left conducts politics
back in January you may remember the
Biden Administration threatened to ban
gas stoves
that's why I think we need to be talking
about regulating gas stoves whether
that's drastically improving emissions
or Banning gas stoves entirely and I
think we ought to keep that possibility
of a band in mind as as you follow along
because it's a powerful tool in our
toolbox and it's a real possibility here
real possibility we're looking to ban
the gas stove so instantly of course the
liberal journals and faked fact Checkers
leapt into action to convince people
that we didn't all hear what we all just
heard
AP fact Focus Biden Administration isn't
Banning gas stoves yes well there were
some comments from a consumer product
safety commission official that we're
going to ban the stoves and everything
but no no we're not going to do that
never mind a New York Times no Biden is
not trying to ban gas stoves we have
here from intelligence or the gas stove
band freak out is the story we need
right now how about Newsweek Republicans
mocked over outraged claims that
government is coming for gas stoves what
a bunch of crazy conspiracy theory
idiots right we have here from
AccuWeather for some reason we're not
taking away your gas stove regulator
tells CNN and then we've got what do we
have Republicans have found their new
Dumb culture War it's from MSNBC big
dumb stupid culture War obviously the
Democrats are not going to take away our
gas stoves and now now
Democrat Governor Kathy hokel has banned
gas stoves in new buildings in New York
existing buildings are not yet affected
but every single new building in the
state of New York will be
according to Governor hogle's spokeslady
which was reported in the New York Times
quote the new law will not have any
loopholes that will undermine the intent
of this measure there will not be any
option for municipalities to opt out
the stoves are just one issue
the libs do this
with every one of their schemes that
conservatives oppose
marriage immigration transiting the kids
in every case the policy that we oppose
is a crazy conspiracy theory that's
totally insane it's never going to
happen what are you talking about until
of course it is firmly established old
news and they tell us too late to fix
I'm Michael knows it's the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show 2024 heating up
a lot of candidates going after a
certain Florida Governor the knives are
out for Rhonda santis which we will get
to in just a second first though I don't
want to move on too quickly from these
liberal journals who just lie and spread
propaganda for the regime and deny
reality and fact check the facts and try
to try to promote falsehood instead of
the facts these guys just had their
favorite event of the year that would be
the White House correspondence
association dinner now the White House
Correspondents association dinner used
to be a Kind of a Funny event in
Washington D.C
and it was when the people who were
reporting on the White House all those
journalists they would get to go and
make jokes about Washington DC and that
usually get a comedian to come into the
room and make fun of them and and the
president would often stop by and make
jokes about them as well and it was all
kind of funny and it was fairly
self-effacing and that is over the White
House Correspondents association dinner
has now become
the Oscars it's hard to differentiate
between the Oscars and the White House
Correspondents association dinner
because these liberal journals have have
puffed themselves up so much and
Hollywood celebrities have degraded
themselves so much they seem to have met
in the middle now and so you lose all of
the glitz and glamor and everything
aspirational that used to make the
Oscars worth watching and you also lose
the self-effacing reality that that used
to give the journals some credibility or
these were just tough guys who were
pursuing a story speaking truth to power
they were grizzled you weren't going to
get one over on them now it's red
carpets now it's photo lines now
Chrissy Teigen who I'm reliably informed
is a celebrity all I know about Chrissy
Teigen is that Candace has a fight with
her or something and they kind of make
funny videos on the internet about her
uh Chrissy Teigen was walking into the
White House correspondence association
dinner dressed to the nines I guess
undressed the nines actually she was
wearing a ton this woman had her her
servants walking behind her carrying the
rest of her gown and the scene was kind
of funny because there were a lot of
global warming protesters who were
surrounding her and the other attendees
screaming about how we need to ban gas
stoves I guess and so but she's walking
in she's got her celebrity husband whose
Name Escapes me he's wearing a tuxedo
and then she has her slaves in the
background carrying the trail of her
dress and so much for the fourth estate
and so much for speaking on behalf of
the little guy and speaking truth to
power there were other celebrities too
there was that gal who Kanye West
briefly dated there were some other
people Vander or something Vanderpump is
that a name of a celebrity I don't know
I'm checked out I don't deal with this
pop culture because it's so desiccated
and shallow and absurd but the White
House Correspondents who were supposed
to be the most grounded people in our
media they're paling around with all
these guys Julia Fox I do remember her
name she was the one who who dated Kanye
West and then do you know the the most
absurd aspect of all about the White
House Correspondents association dinner
this is the part
the grates on me the most
it's not that they want their fancy
dinner with all their celebrities to
hobnob around and not oppose the
establishment but be part of the
establishment that I've come to expect
the part that grates on me the most
about the White House Correspondents
association dinner
is that they refer to it as nerd prom
nerd prom which implies that these
people are knowledgeable and intelligent
which are two adjectives that I don't
think you could say describe the
Washington DC press course certainly not
the White House Press Corps
nerd prom
a lot of people don't use nerd in this
way anymore this is still the primary
definition of nerd though
some people think nerd just means you're
really hyper enthusiastic and focused on
some Niche subject matter
but you know it does imply intelligence
I couldn't remember if I was just going
crazy so I looked it up in
Merriam-Webster and it says primary
definition
a person devoted to intellectual
academic or technical Pursuits or
interests
does that Define Washington D.C journals
to you the people who cover the White
House
no not at all
wood that it did there have been times
when when journalists have been uh
associated with intelligence with
knowledge in a particular subject area
that's gone
that's gone the journals in the liberal
media establishment which attends this
dinner they are much less informed on
these issues
they take these sorts of issues much
less seriously than the average person
on the street
perhaps that's why our political order
is crumbling a little bit that's why you
gotta check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 president Trump
recently issued a warning from his
Mar-A-Lago home quote our currency is
crashing and will soon no longer be the
world standard which will be our
greatest defeat frankly in 200 years
there are three reasons the central
banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
that is gold and you can own it in a tax
sheltered retirement account with the
help of Birch gold that is right Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K maybe from a previous
employer into an IRA into gold the best
part you don't pay a penny out of pocket
just text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 for
your free info kit they will hold your
hand through the whole process think
about this when currencies fail gold is
a safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an eight plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 get your free
info kit on gold text Knolls it's 98
98.98
speaking of supposed nerd experts
Dr fauci our old buddy Dr fauci he's
back on CNN speaking to Christiane
amanpur
who drew rightly dubbed Christian I'm a
poor journalist
interviewing Dr fauci we're now three
years after
two weeks to slow the spread and we're
trying to make sense of what has
happened over the last
two years and Dr fauci says look we got
to stop playing the blame game
was the closing of the schools to
draconian
how much of a delay did the fact that
nobody fully understood the asymptomatic
spread of this nobody figured out that
it could actually bust through certain
vaccine levels as well what are the real
takeaways in the real lessons yes I
think we have to get away from the blame
game because so many of the things that
you have mentioned were unknowns at the
time and I kept on saying over and over
again we've got to get the children back
to school as quickly as possible we've
got to get them in school safely and
we've got to make sure that there are
not essentially out of school at home
getting all of the negative consequences
different parts of the country
interpreted that differently there were
schools that stayed closed far too long
and longer than they should have and
there were those that essentially didn't
close at all
I guess you probably should have been a
little clearer Dr fauci
I I love he says let me get a step play
in the blame game we just didn't know
okay and then but then I was very clear
it was totally unclear but I was very
clear and then the people who
interpreted me they they didn't realize
how clear it was so they interpreted it
wrong sometimes and anyway it's not my
fault
whatever whatever went wrong that's not
my fault whatever went right that was
that was all me I I am the science bow
down before me
you dirty peasants
I am the science
all hail the science
you gotta stop playing that blame game
it wasn't clear we just didn't know we
didn't know that's funny because I knew
I knew and you knew
and my friends knew generally and your
friends probably knew too how is it
that's so weird because I don't have any
degrees from Johns Hopkins I've never
worked at MIT I don't I don't read
peer-reviewed scientific studies on
epidemiology and yet I knew somehow that
putting a hanky on my face wasn't going
to prevent me from Catching the virus
I knew that standing six feet away from
people
wasn't going to really do anything
I knew that not visiting my grandmother
wasn't going to save people's lives
I knew that that experimental drug that
they rushed through
might not be the most effective thing at
stopping I knew
you know I hate to say I told you so but
I guess I'm saying it a lot over and
over again and you're you've probably
been saying it a lot over and over again
for the last three years so how is it
that we all knew
and Dr fauci didn't
don't we need to answer that question
that the people in charge were wrong
about everything
and ordinary Joe Blow on the street who
doesn't have a particularly specialized
education he was right about everything
I was at the whole journalist class was
totally wrong
and the readers of the newspapers and
the websites and the viewers of the TV
shows we were largely right
we were so right that we would
contradict them
and then big Tech would come in and they
would censor us for doing that
they would take our show off the air
sometimes for doing that
what how do you explain all of it I
think we need a lot more of the blame
game
and and I think the Liberals agree with
me
the Liberals right now are indicting
Donald Trump in New York
for
making an in-kind contribution to his
own campaign
seven years ago which would not be a
crime at all but they're trying to twist
it and pretend that it's a misdemeanor
and then they're trying to twist that
and say that it's a felony years after
the statute of limitations on the
misdemeanor would have run out but it's
not really a misdemeanor because
candidates are allowed to donate as much
to their campaign as they want
that was seven years ago we're still
playing that blame game
no we're just not supposed to play the
blame game when it comes to the ruling
class that shut our world down for no
reason
well for no good reason
they shut it down and they they
themselves got more power and they shut
it down and they themselves got more
money was the largest transfer of wealth
in human history
from the lower class to the upper class
and yet we're not we're not supposed to
play that lame game
Move Along sheep we won it's a
conspiracy theory it's all fake you're
all totally crazy and yeah you were
right but it's old news Move Along Move
Along what the confidence on that guy
wouldn't you say amazing that kind of
undue confidence speaking of undue
confidence Whoopi Goldberg on The View
has just come out to scold Christians
because
Christians don't want to trans the kids
and whoopee
is convinced
that the Bible is very very clear about
how we should trans the kids oh my God
this is a party that says we believe in
parents rights you're telling me that as
a parent I don't I'm not smart enough to
decide if my child and I need to have
gender affirming our doctors are not
involved what is going so I can't my I
can't decide what my kid reads I can't
decide for my child what my child says
is going on you're telling me your
beliefs your and they keep saying it and
I keep saying what Bible are you reading
yeah because God was really clear very
clear
God was really clear that we need to
trans the kids and have the kids read
gay porn in schools
so says Whoopi Goldberg
I love too she focuses on she says these
parents these parents aren't even able
to show their decide what their kids are
going to read in schools
which by the way the whole issue over
the gay porn in the schools right now is
that parents don't want their kids to be
exposed to gay porn in schools it's the
it's the teachers and the weirdos and
The ideologues Who want the kids to read
gay porn in schools the parents are
saying please don't do that and the libs
are coming in and saying your parents
don't have that right and Whoopi flips
it and she says parents should be able
to to teach their kids gay porn
but then of course you you run up
against this issue which is there's only
one book that you're not allowed to read
in schools
there's only one book that our Supreme
Court has said you're not allowed to be
taught in schools that of course would
be the Bible which Whoopi says that
she's quoting
it would seem likely to me that Whoopi
Goldberg has not read the Bible I know
the Bible does not say we ought to train
the kids the point I want to make on it
is actually has nothing to do with
transiting the kids or Whoopi Goldberg
the point I want to make on it is that
line she says
she says it's so clear the Bible is very
clear
when someone says
the Bible is very clear
without any other context
you should be very skeptical of whatever
follows
wise people Avail themselves of History
so in in the modern world we just take
one sentence and we say well there's no
other context matters as dairy Dawes
said there is no outside text so it
doesn't matter what we know about the
author or the time in which he lived or
the works that he's referring to or the
great conversation that's taking place
over the course of history no all that
matters is the words on the page and
then whatever interpretation I want to
foist upon the words that's how modern
people view things and it's not just on
the left even some people who would
consider themselves more Centrist or
even right wing will do that
especially when it comes to the Bible
but we don't have to do that that's a
very liberal modern approach
conservatives can Avail ourselves of the
wisdom of the ages
because our own stock of reason is
relatively paltry
even even those of us speaking and
listening to the show right now who I
know were definitely probably a couple
notches above
the people who attend the White House
correspondence association dinner in
terms of understanding and wisdom and
overall handsomeness I know but believe
it or not even we
don't know very much about very much and
so it's prudent to Avail ourselves of
the wisdom of the ages and so if Whoopi
had said okay I read somewhere in the
Bible that we should trans the kids I
don't know what verse I saw that in but
let's let's look at the history of the
church
has the church ever taught that it's
good to trans the kids no oh okay so
where did I get that idea what is more
likely that every Christian that ever
came before me including all the great
doctors of the church Saint Thomas
Aquinas Saint August and all that they
were all wrong and I dot doctor of the
church Whoopi Goldberg am right or that
I got it wrong what's more likely
obviously the latter
you actually just saw this play out in
Hungary the pope went and visited
Hungary
Hungary strong right-wing government
doing a lot of great stuff
Pope Francis summer times it talks a
little bit in a confusing way a papa
Francesco was a misinterpreted by a
Republican Journal a newspaper in Italy
and he'll say things and then sometimes
the journalists are in fact
misinterpreting him sometimes what the
Holy Father says is somewhat ambiguous
but what he said in Hungary was not
ambiguous at all and it shocked a lot of
liberals I will translate what the Pope
says
this is a nefarious path of ideological
colonization that eliminates differences
as in the case of gender culture which
eliminate differences
prioritizes other things reducing
freedom for example and creating an
insane right to abortion
that is always a tragic
how beautiful and
for birth
and family
we have countries in Europe where the
median age is 46 or 48 years old
what if we have a country
in which the growth and uniqueness of
each individual is preserved
it's a great idea so in there he comes
out in favor of hungary's initiative to
increase birth rates in Europe comes out
against abortion articulates that this
is insane to suggest there's such a
thing as a right to abortion and he says
that gender ideology is is crazy that
it's an ideological colonization
it's contrary to reality
but this is a liberal Pope what do you
mean the liberal Pope
is opposed to abortion yes because the
church has taught consistently from day
one that abortion is completely
unacceptable we see this in the Bible we
see this in the Commandment against
committing murder
we see this in the scriptural defenses
of children we also see this in the ddk
that earliest catechism of the church
going back to the earliest days of the
church
what about gender Theory well we see
this in the Bible in the beginning God
created man both male and female created
he them we see this in the
complementarity of the sexes in the
description of marriage in Genesis and
in the gospel of Saint Matthew and we
see this throughout the history of the
church so you could say yes Pope Francis
is liberal I'm not suggesting that that
Pope Francis really is desirous of
upending church teaching on gender
ideology but he's merely constrained by
tradition I totally take the Pope in his
word I think he's sincere when he says
he thinks abortion is insane and he
thinks that gender ideology is crazy in
a colonization and he says it's good to
have young people being born
but why is it that the pope would think
that
and why would he advocate for that even
when he has a reputation as a liberal
because there is no way to overcome not
only
the clear scripture
but that that weight of History this is
why the libs have to attack history
this is why the libs have to turn your
eyes away from history
this is why the libs have to get you to
focus only on your unfettered reason and
you as an individual totally divorced
from your family
from your local community
from your nation from your democracy and
from what Chesterton would call that
that greatest democracy of all the
Democracy of the Dead which is not
merely confined to people who happen to
be walking about the Earth at this time
now when you don't want to look dead
when you want to look young and vibrant
and hot and sexy you got to check out
geniusell right now go to genucel.com
Knowles are you looking for the perfect
Mother's Day gift that will make the
women in your life feel pampered and
appreciated our friends at genu cell
have you covered geniusell's most
popular package is specially curated to
nourish and rejuvenate skin right now
they're offering 70 7-0 off this package
which includes their Ultra retinol and
Dark Spot Corrector our producer Jacob
uses genucel's Ultra retinol and
nighttime moisturizer that contains a
powerful retinol alternative to visibly
reduce the appearance of Fine Lines
wrinkles and skin discoloration without
the irritation of retinol it leaves
producer Jacob looking much brighter and
much more even than he otherwise wood
younger healthier more vibrant than ever
I love all of Jamie sales products I
particularly love their under eye bag
treatment because I only consume tobacco
and alcohol and black coffee so it does
it really helps I I really love
geniusell uh go check it out right now
especially because I love their founder
who's a Coptic Christian from Egypt who
came over for the American dream
geniusell's most popular package during
their mother day's sale is 70 off at
genucel.com Knowles every most popular
package features their Ultra retinol and
Dark Spot Corrector get a complimentary
Spa Essentials box with every package
from now until Mother's Day they'll even
upgrade you to free priority shipping
geniusell.com Knowles
stop right there
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking Michael
how how do you get your hair so shiny
and voluminous and spectacular the
answer is Jeremy's razor shampoo and
conditioner that's right Jeremy's razors
is more than just a razor company
fighting to protect what you believe in
Jeremy's razors there's also a Men's
Grooming brand that does not hate men
and this quaff that you see here is
fortified thanks to Jeremy's tea tree
and Argan Oil infused shampoo and
conditioner
that's not all oh no
Jeremy's also has an exfoliating
charcoal body wash made with a hydrating
aloe vera Eucalyptus in just the right
amount of pomegranate you do not want
too much pomegranate in your charcoal
body wash okay that that way lies
Madness the men's care products that you
see here are made with natural
ingredients
they're 100 sulfate free paraben free
woke free made right here in the US of a
head on over to jeremesraisers.com to
kick woke companies out of your bathroom
today
speaking of religion good and bad and
right and wrong in Boston over the
weekend
a bunch of satanists met up
in what is now being called the largest
gathering of satanists ever
it was called Satan Khan big conference
for satanists they're making a lot of
satanic symbols wearing lots of
pentagrams and weird goat head imagery
and horns and stuff
looking like a bunch of weirdos and
doing really bad things
they're shredding Bibles
they were they were engaging in they're
performing unbaptizing ceremonies which
is not possible baptism leaves uh an
indelible mark on the soul but these
Jokers think they can unbaptize you they
were uh shredding pro-cop Flags you know
The Thin Blue Line blue lives matter
they were promoting transgenderism they
were promoting abortion
they had talked sins of the flesh
Satanism and self-pleasure promoting uh
what Woody Allen euphemistically called
sex with someone you love the sort of
thing that one does associated with
pornography uh they they had a talk
reclaiming the trans body
and it's it's easy to
kind of just mock these guys or even to
feel a great deal of pity for them
because you think oh these are just a
bunch of Misfit weirdos dressing up in
goat horns and making The Rock The Rock
and Roll symbol and it's no big deal but
they're promoting pretty bad stuff I
mean transcing the castrating children
that's that's not great that's a bad
thing to promote uh murdering babies
through abortion
it's not great these guys raise money
for abortion clinics to kill babies so
it gets it gets pretty dark it
it'd be easy to laugh at them if the
consequences of this stuff were not so
dire and of course they uh worship the
prince of Lies
the father of Lies so the only reason I
even bring this up
is not to call too much attention to
these people but
when conservatives point out that this
stuff is satanic
that these ideas that seem like they are
just ordinary political issues
we want to take down the cops abolish
the police
well we want to allow men who think
they're women to just dress up like
women and they're they really are women
we're going to establish in our law that
they're really women we want women to
have choice and have the right to
control their own bodies by murdering
their children we we just we that's what
we support and a lot of people including
on the right
then go these are just
just political issues where you have
your opinion and I have my opinion we're
in a debate maybe meet in the middle but
no
people who are serious about these
issues
recognize that
they
they come down to Good and Evil
there is a satanic element
to lots of these issues that are being
pushed by the left Tucker Carlson may
have lost his job for pointing that out
but it's so clear
when conservatives point out that there
is a satanic element to all of these
issues you don't need to take our word
for it the satanists agree
people who actually worship
the devil and most normal people in the
middle
they
it's not that they can't wrap their head
around transgenderism or around abortion
or around defund the police they can't
wrap their head around the fact
that some people
explicitly worship the devil
they think well that's a silly
superstition
that's just a silly stupid superstition
you guys you're all Jokers okay you
people who worship the devil are Jokers
and you people who go to church or
Jokers and me a Bourgeois secular
liberal whose most important weekly
ritual is going to brunch on Sunday and
maybe going to a yoga class I'm the
reasonable one here I can't help but
point out if you look at all of human
history in every society everywhere on
Earth
you see
an acknowledgment of the devil
and
an acknowledgment of
if not the one true God at least
intuitions of the one true God and an
acknowledgment of moral reality and the
idea that some things are better than
other things
so who's the mistaken one who's the
crazy superstitious one
the the people who
are behaving and perceiving the world in
in line with how everyone has always
done so
or the handful of modern secularists who
think it's all just bunk
and we're all just bags of meat and
chemicals and our only purpose is to get
pleasure and all those higher things
they're they're just fanciful
to quote Antonin Scalia in an interview
with a New York Magazine lib journo some
years ago now she was mocking him for
being religious and he said you know
yeah I believe in God in heaven I even
believe in hell and the devil many more
intelligent people than you or me have
believed in the devil
on this point on Good and Evil a
horrible story uh came out last week I
want to get to it though MS-13
is this uh gang that people just
associate with running drugs and
ferrying people across the border and we
know they're bad and they've got these
face tattoos but I don't think people
know how bad they are
an MS-13 gangster uh who was recently
released from prison on parole of course
I was just charged for murdering an Uber
Eats driver in a case that police are
calling demonic
in Holiday Florida Oscar Solas 30 year
old MS-13 gangster he was arrested on
April 24th for alleged late murdering
and dismembering 59 year old Randall
cook who was a husband and a stepfather
who was just delivering food to the
gangster's home it was his last drop off
of the week and this guy
this gangster decided that he was just
going to murder the ubereats driver just
cuz
and so we we think in the modern
secular world of MS-13 is oh they're
just a drug gang oh they're they run
prostitution Rings yeah they're just
Thugs and criminals for sure but that's
it
MS-13 was founded by satanists by people
who in their own conception of
themselves
served Satan and worshiped Satan MS-13
regularly engages in Satanic ritual and
sacrifice MS-13 venerates Santa Muerte
this demonic personification of saint of
holy death Saint death
nothing holy about it of course
I'm I'm not trying to convince you well
I am trying to convince you to go to
church but that's not the reason I bring
up this story
I'm I'm not doing it simply to tell you
you know get your life in order and
recognize good and evil in your own life
and stop being
stop pursuing values and start pursuing
virtue and all the rest of it
the reason I bring up this story is if
you only look at this story through the
modern secular lens you miss the whole
thing you it doesn't make any sense the
only way that a story like this makes
any sense is if there is such a thing as
the demonic and such a thing as the holy
if there is spiritual warfare if the the
way that we now describe as old and
superstitious and crazy that that our
civilization has viewed reality for its
history
which is that there is good and evil
we're in this this battle uh where where
the church militant if if you don't view
it through that lens you miss the whole
story here then this ubereats story just
becomes all local random crime this is
why liberal politicians whenever there's
a shooting that is convenient for them
to talk about
they'll say oh it's senseless
so it's senseless
often these shootings are not senseless
oh this shoot the shootings in downtown
Chicago are just so senseless
no there there is a kind of a logic to
these shootings it's just that
the logic involves aspects of moral
reality that the modern liberal
secularists can't acknowledge so what
are we going to do about it there's
great news out of Missouri a Missouri
Judge has just appointed a special
prosecutor to investigate
one of the George soros-backed DA's in
St Louis
Soros most notably among the liberal
donors because George Soros is probably
the most prominent funder of leftist
causes in the world today and he does it
through his open Society foundation and
he does it through lots of different
tentacles of his political power uh
George Soros has had these District
Attorneys and prosecutors elected
these races are super easy to win
because people don't put a lot of money
into them so if you put any money into
them at all you can often get your guys
installed and then the prosecutors just
don't prosecute the crimes
and the satanists in Boston cheer
because they want to defund the police
and they don't want crime to be punished
they want crime to flourish and they
want civil order to break down
so the the soros-backed prosecutors they
say yeah we're not we're not going to do
that what can we do these guys were
elected right one Missouri Judge
has announced that he's going to appoint
a special prosecutor to build a criminal
contempt case against
the St Louis prosecutor Kimberly M
Gardner who was bankrolled by Soros
because
this prosecutor Kimberly Gardner
won't prosecute crime
and as the judge said judge Michael
Noble
the circuit attorney's office appears to
be a rudderless ship of Chaos
Ms Gardner is a circuit attorney it is
her duty to manage the caseload of each
staff member Mr desilatz was one of the
staff members has approximately 104
felony cases any prudent practitioner
would expect such a caseload to create
countless irreconcilable conflicts does
not appear she's made any reasonable
efforts to prevent the resulting chaos
it appears that Ms Gardner has complete
indifference and conscious disregard for
the judicial process which is obviously
the case so what do conservatives think
about wielding this this judicial power
to use a prosecutor to go after another
prosecutor who is elected but he was
elected with a ton of funding of the
libs who have their power centers in
financiers such as George Soros they get
a lot of backing from the media what do
we think about this wielding of
government power
hip hip hooray that's what I say I say
this is great and and the conservatives
who know what time it is the
conservatives who understand how our
constitution Works lowercase C the way
that the government actually functions
today not Capital C Constitution not
school has rock Bill up on Capitol Hill
no the the way the government actually
works we realize that the only path
forward is not to just give some other
lecture on The Federalist Papers
that can be fine in edifying for
students but what we have to do
is crush the libs power centers we need
to wield the state to go after their
prosecutors who don't prosecute crime we
need to defund and dismantle their media
apparatus we need to tax their
University endowments we need to wield
the State against their corporations
when as in the case of Florida the the
corporations like Disney are trying to
undermine the will of the people and
their representatives in Florida to say
that we don't want to trans the kids
Disney comes and says we're gonna and
your kids and
that there's a similarity between the
Pete bootage voice well hey guys hey
everybody judge and the Mickey Mouse
voice I don't know is that a coincidence
is is there some deeper meaning there
I'm not so sure but all I know is that
when the CEO of Disney comes in and says
that's right we're going to put your kid
on puberty blockers I don't want to hear
any lectures about how the free market
says that we can never ever wield the
state and the collectivist forces
against Disney no okay I've had enough
of that trancing my kid that's too much
all right we're not we're not doing that
there is nothing conservative about
allowing corporations to destroy our
country upend our social order and trans
our kids we need to wield power in a
just way in a prudent way but we've got
to do it where the game is already lost
my favorite comment on Friday is from my
name was taken LOL it's a good name says
assisted suicide for toddlers no they
basically just approved post-birth
abortion
that's true we talked last week about
how the Netherlands
has just legalized
euthanasia
which is assisted suicide
for toddlers
ages 1 through 12.
you might say hold on
a three-year-old cannot really consent
to anything
three-year-old can't go buy a pack of
cigarettes
three-year-old can't join the military
three-year-old can't buy a beer
three-year-old can't consent to sexual
activity obviously and yet now
increasingly we're seeing young people
five six seven eight-year-olds can
consent to sexual mutilation procedures
hold on five six seven year olds four
three two one-year-olds can consent to
Suicide uh no that's just called Murder
that's called partial birth abortion
it's another example where it's a phrase
that the conservatives used mockingly
ironically we say these liberals they
love abortion so much they don't just
want third trimester abortions they want
fourth and fifth trimester abortions
well now they've got it
it's all a crazy wacky bizarre
conspiracy theory until the libs firmly
establish it and then they say it's too
late to do anything about it
okay getting on to 2024.
knives are out
and the knives are out not primarily for
Donald Trump they're out
for Ron DeSantis our friend Vivek
ramaswamy was on Meet the Press
with Chuck Todd
and he did not spend his time really
going after Trump he's he has gone after
Trump by the way people are saying that
vague has never attacked Trump that's
not true he's going after Trump but he's
reserving most of his ire for governor
DeSantis here's where Ron DeSantis
really lost it here he's gone on the
wrong path as he claimed and this part
actually sounded good to me Disney
should have never had crony capitalist
lobbying related privileges in the first
place here's the part he doesn't mention
one of those crony capitalist privileges
was and I think the most relevant one
was codified into law by none other than
Ron DeSantis in 2021. so Florida passed
this political anti-discrimination
statute which I applauded at the time
said if you operate internet companies
this includes streaming services like
Disney does that you can't engage in
Viewpoint discrimination now here's the
funny dirty little secret of that they
wrote into a last-minute exception into
that law for anyone who also operates a
theme park more than 25 acres in the
State of Florida that's crony capitalism
and so the irony is Ron DeSantis who's
now railing against crony capitalism and
rolling that back was the one who
actually passed that into law for the
case of Disney so I think that
undermines the credibility of his
Crusade I prefer to get to root causes
rather than doing political stuff months
okay put aside the DeSantis
Disney policy of it all for a second
because it's a little unclear did Disney
out Fox DeSantis by holding two public
meetings before their board voted on
such and such and so and so did Disney
get the last laugh or has DeSantis
gotten the last lap because they've
pointed to some other older law that
Disney did not follow which means that
actually the Florida will be able to
wheel the control over the Reedy Creek
District which allowed Disney previously
self-governance I don't know I don't
know the courts will work it out
that that is almost a side issue at this
point the most interesting part of the
Vex appearance
and the appearance of other
presidential candidates and the fact
that they're all going after DeSantis
signals to me
that
they believe Trump will be the nominee
and so they're they're reserving their
iron their fire for DeSantis as the
number two guy because they don't want
to go too hard after Trump because they
think that Trump is today still the most
likely nominee and I know that everybody
in the conservative media they are very
bullish on DeSantis getting the
nomination I think Ron DeSantis is a
phenomenal Governor this is in no way a
criticism of Ron DeSantis but I'm just
looking at the numbers
Trump has a huge lead over Ron DeSantis
and Trump's numbers are getting better
and Governor DeSantis numbers are
getting worse now I know Ron DeSantis
has not announced he's running for
president yet
I think he's expected to do so
over the next few weeks
but
Ron DeSantis needs to start getting
aggressive if he wants to get the
nomination
because
what the DeSantis Camp seems to believe
now is yeah it appears like Trump is
winning but
that's an illusion once this thing
really gets going DeSantis is going to
take off well perception
can
collapse into reality in campaigns
if every day for the next month
Ron DeSantis is perceived as losing as
losing Ground And if every day for the
next month Trump is perceived as gaining
ground and solidifying his hold over the
Republican Party
then that's going to collapse into a
reality of a much harder campaign for
Ron DeSantis
and presidential candidates are very
capable people who have very good guts
who can smell blood and if it feels like
Ron DeSantis is vulnerable in the
campaign and he's the big number two guy
that they got to get past either to have
a shot at taking on Donald Trump or
Trump gets a nomination and they have a
they have a shot at being in the
administration they are going to do that
the Proto campaign for DeSantis
is going to have to get more aggressive
or they're going to be inviting more
attacks from the other candidates
you're seeing these same sorts of
attacks not just from the outside of the
box more
right-wing figures in the race like
the vague you're seeing it from the
squishes too like ASA Hutchinson former
governor of Arkansas who is also running
in 2024 who's he going after is he going
after Trump no he's going after DeSantis
I don't like what Disney said about the
legislation that I would have supported
in Florida but it's not the role of
government to punish a business when you
disagree with what they're saying or a
position that they take if that was the
view of a republican then we're going to
be in all kinds of trouble in our
businesses in blue States if they start
punishing businesses for taking a more
conservative speech or position and so I
don't understand a conservative
punishing a business that's the largest
employer in the state in Arkansas and as
Governors we recruit industry we support
our industry because it provides jobs
and we're not dictating to them what
their speech is to me that's a
conservative position and you air when
you go otherwise
why would a republican ever want to
speak out against a business
because
believe it or not
some things are more important than
money
we used to know that
didn't conservatives especially used to
know that
we forgot it somewhere over the last 30
40 years
this this created the crisis in the
Republican party that finally exploded
with the Trump movement
the Republicans had always said were the
party of family values were the party of
tradition were the party of custom were
the party of what is good and right and
just or the part of the Bible where the
party of religion
and also nothing is more important than
GDP the the free market is the most
sacred Creation in it's not even a
creation oh it predates us it's
pre-political
this the free market no one can ever
meddle with the free market if a
business wants to do anything that is
their right including transiting our
kids and how dare you criticize that the
business for doing that
no
this was a battle
between
the Bible
and Ein Rand
this is a buy a battle not just the
Bible but the whole civilization that
the Bible
uh outlined and that Christianity
animated That civilization versus
modernity
once that once Christendom cracked up
and you saw the geographic crack up of
Christendom beginning five centuries ago
you saw the
um
intellectual crackup of Christendom well
I guess right around the same time
then you had all these new kind of crazy
strains perverse strains that started to
come out of that
one of them was this idea that all that
matters is the material world
and that we're material beings and if
that is true then really all that
matters is money
and there was this bizarre schizophrenia
on the right
which is the Republican Party would talk
about how we need tradition and we need
to defend our way of life and also we
need creative destruction and nothing
matters more than GDP and that didn't
make sense and ASA Johnson is
articulating that view
that view that it's been popular for 30
40 years now
and I think that that view has collapsed
I don't think there's a ton of room for
that so if if DeSantis is getting
knocked for opposing that view
this anthis should probably make a
campaign commercial out of that
criticism okay it's music Monday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code Knowles Canada wlas at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]